expresses his gratitude to prime
minister kiriakos mitsatakis the
government is officially closing Moria
one of the largest refugee camps in
Greece both men believe it'll help them
get re-elected I'm very happy that the
more Eddie's Grace no longer exists as
you can as you can see it belongs to the
past and we have every reason to be kind
of optimistic about the future I think
we've been able to to manage the
migration issue in a tough but Humane
manner Moria was one of Europe's Most
overcrowded and squalid camps most of
its residents lived in tents and Huts
two and a half years ago they burned it
down this is Moria once home to some 25
000 refugees many were born here grew up
here or died here the Island's Refugee
population is now a tenth of that number
this government reflects the complete
change in Europe's Refugee policy over
the past few years it proudly proclaims
that it's prevented some seven hundred
thousand illegal entries protecting
Europe's open internal borders and
abolishing the status of these estrogen
Islands as Europe's buffer zones but
really the problem is just moving out of
sight to the middle of a forest 40
kilometers away
a vast new camp to accommodate 5 000
people is under construction it'll have
proper housing running water and heating
but mitotakis didn't stop here it seems
the government doesn't want to draw
attention to this site just as many of
the Islanders don't want any refugee
camps
some people said the refugees brought
AIDS and Ebola and that they would sleep
with your women and it worked they
turned the population against them the
turning point in policy came in March
2020 when the Turkish government
announced it would no longer prevent
refugees from Crossing its borders into
Greece since then Greece and the EU have
treated the refugee issue as a security
problem not just a humanitarian one
conditions may not be ideal here but
Asylum Seekers are free to walk to town
and spend their cash handouts Europe's
New Deal is a better Camp far from
civilization John saropoulos Al Jazeera
lesbos